[Aplausos]
es la ley estrella del gobierno bailén
con cerca de 750 mil millones de dólares
la legislación conocida como la ley de
reducción de la inflación es el Macro
proyecto de gastos de Gran envergadura
que busca realizar inversiones para la
reducción del déficit del país y atacar
Los Altos datos inflacionarios resumido
en tres frentes Busca solucionar
problemas de la atención médica los
impuestos y el cambio climático cuando
promulgó la ley el mandatario
estadounidense la describió como un
proyecto legislativo histórico que
reducirá los costos para las familias
estadounidenses combatirá la crisis
climática reducir al déficit y
finalmente hará que las corporaciones
más grandes paguen su parte justan
impuestos dentro de los grandes cambios
propone un impuesto mínimo para las
corporaciones con ingresos de al menos
mil millones de dólares permite que
Medicare negocie el precio de ciertos
medicamentos recetados y en ocasiones
específicas Determine su valor con base
en la inflación propone Un aumento en la
capacidad de recaudación del servicio de
impuestos internos extiende hasta 2025
la expansión temporal de los créditos
Fiscales para primas que expiraban en
2022 y contempla más de 400 mil millones
de dólares en nuevas inversiones para
impulsar la industria de la energía
verde Este es el punto que rechaza la
Unión Europea ya que le otorga créditos
Fiscales a consumidores que compren
vehículos eléctricos fabricados en
Estados Unidos
Pero según expertos el impacto en la
inflación es sumamente pequeño y el
cambio no se reflejará en el mediano
plazo según el modelo de presupuesto de
penum warton la organización no
partidista que crea análisis económicos
del impacto fiscal de las políticas
públicas de Estados Unidos la ley
Incluso producirá un aumento muy pequeño
en la inflación Durante los próximos
años hasta 0,05 puntos porcentuales en
2024 la agencia Federal que le entrega
información presupuestaria al congreso
asegura que el cambio en la inflación
será insignificante en 2022 y 2023
cambiandola entre 0,1 puntos
porcentuales por debajo y 0,1 puntos
porcentuales por encima de lo que se
encuentra actualmente en octubre el
índice de precios al consumidor se ubicó
en 7,7% interanual Y aunque fue menor
que los meses inmediatamente anteriores
estuvo en máximos desde 1982 sin embargo
aquellos que apoyaron la ley creen que
su ejecución permite que las soluciones
que lleguen al país beneficia a sus
ciudadanos sin importar el cambio de
gobierno